sulfates fatty alcohols silicones
preservatives why are they in shampoo
and conditioner and do you need to avoid
them hi i'm michelle chemistry phd and
cosmetic chemist today we're doing a
deep dive into some of the key
ingredients in hair care products this
video was sponsored by the ordinary who
turned a lot of people into skincare
nerds with their focus on ingredients
and now they're moving into hair care
let's start with shampoo to me the best
way to approach analyzing formulas is to
think what is the point of this product
what is its function shampoo obviously
cleans your hair and scalp just like
skin your scalp produces sebum which we
usually think of as oil this oil keeps
your skin and scalp nice and soft and it
also travels along the hair to keep that
soft as well but sometimes we have too
much oil some of us like me more than
others it also tends to stick to things
like dirt dust skin flakes and pollution
you might also use styling products that
need to be washed off the problem is if
you just try to use water to degrasify
everything a bit it usually doesn't work
very well because oil and water don't
mix so to make them mix we use a shampoo
and the key ingredients in the shampoo
that clean are surfactants surfactants
are really useful ingredients because
they have a head that likes water and a
tail that likes oil and so instead of
repelling each other the surfactants
allow the oil to basically be smuggled
into the water in lots of tiny droplets
and then you can wash that away down the
drain there are surfactants in tons of
different products because getting oil
and water to stay together is really
useful for cleaning the best surfactants
are anionic surfactants these have a
negatively charged head and they're used
in tons of cleaning products shampoo
obviously but also laundry detergent
dishwashing detergent body washes and
face cleansers some of the anionic
surfaces that you might have seen in
your shampoos and cleanses are sulfates
sarcoisonates torays and isothionates
traditional soaps also have anionic
surfactants called carboxylates so
that's what the sulfates are doing but
why are people talking about
sulfate-free well a lot of it is based
on misinformation once you start digging
into the science behind shampoos you
start to realize that limiting yourself
to self-a-free shampoos
doesn't really make sense sulfate
surfactants are a diverse group of
ingredients that behave in different
ways and on top of that they can be
combined in formulas in lots of
different ways to give very different
shampoos it's a bit like eggs in a
recipe just seeing eggs in the
ingredients list doesn't tell you
whether they use the whites or the yolks
or a mix how the food tastes or whether
you'll like it
unless you have an egg allergy in which
case you probably should avoid it unless
you really like pain or you're vegan so
generalizing cell phase and products
doesn't really work it isn't like
shampoos with sulfates are always
harsher or more irritating or strip
color faster than sulfate-free shampoos
there is a lot of overlap sulfates are
some of the most commonly used anionic
surfactants in personal care products
the two you'll see most in shampoos are
sodium lauryl sulfate sls and sodium
laureth sulfate sles these sound pretty
similar but they're actually very
different sodium lauryl sulfate is the
more famous one and it has a bad
reputation which has now spread to other
sulfates it has a narrow structure and
that means it can potentially absorb
into skin more easily and keep
irritating for longer if sls is in a
formula on its own in a high
concentration then it will probably be
quite irritating and this is one of the
big reasons why it has this irritant
reputation a lot of the time in
peer-reviewed studies and in dermatology
patch testing sls is used by itself to
make sure it is the specific ingredient
that someone is reacting to but this
also means it isn't in its usual
environment which is in a product with a
lot of other ingredients that change how
it interacts with skin and with hair
there are lots of formulating tricks
that are usually used in sls products
here are some of them creating mixed
micelles by combining sls with other
surfactants this makes sls less likely
to wander off on its own into your skin
or hair
it's like peer pressure but for
molecules adding polymers that act as a
raft to hold onto free sls molecules
again this is so it can't run away into
your skin or hair adding skin protecting
ingredients like humectants and
antioxidants that can prevent or reverse
some of the irritation now sles
sodium laureth sulfate actually isn't
one single ingredient it's actually a
category of ingredients that are all
listed under the same name in an
ingredients list ingredient lists don't
really lie but they don't really tell
you the full story either sles is
ethoxylated which means it's sls but
with a bunch of ethoxy units inserted
next to the sulfur like this the number
of units can change and this changes how
the specific type of sles interacts with
everything else water oil or other
surfactant molecules having these ethoxy
units means that less sles will wander
off on its own into your skin compared
to sls ethoxylation also makes the
molecule bigger which means it doesn't
penetrate skin as easily and is more
gentle it's a bit like walking through a
crowd if you want to get through a crowd
faster you try to hunch and make
yourself smaller you don't spread your
arms out there's one study that found
that sles was gentler than sls which is
not very surprising but it was also
gentler than a whole bunch of
non-surface effectors that you often
find in sulfate-free products and on top
of this formulators can use the same
formulating tricks that i mentioned
before to make sles products even
gentler now with color fading
i have a strong personal interest in
this as you can probably tell when i
first dyed my hair four years ago i use
sulfate-free shampoos because that's
what everyone says is best for keeping
your hair color for longer except
i hated all the selfie-free shampoos
that i tried and i spent a lot of money
on them because i went with a lot of
very fancy brands i ended up just going
back to sulphate shampoos and i didn't
actually notice much of a difference
with my hair color fading recently i got
to see some experimental data on color
fading that confirmed what i noticed
happening with my hair with color fading
there are some differences between
different shampoo formulas as you'd
expect from everything i've said so far
there is a lot of overlap between self a
full and sulfate free shampoos the ph of
the shampoo actually made a bigger
difference than whether or not it had
sulfates higher ph more alkaline
shampoos will leech some dyes out faster
but by far the biggest thing that made a
difference was just water just washing
coloured hair in water without shampoo
leeches out a ton of dye the differences
between different shampoos are tiny
compared to washing versus not washing
so my problem was that a lot of
sulfate-free shampoos were formulated to
be too gentle to clean my scalp and hair
properly i have a pretty oily scalp and
so that meant that i either wash my hair
every day or i just suffered with sticky
limp hair and an itchy scalp and
sometimes that happen even if i wash
daily using a shampoo with sulfates let
me wash my hair less often and so i
actually ended up with less fading
sulfate's also quite cheap which a lot
of people paint as a bad thing that
companies are just using cheap
ingredients to save money even though
there might be better more expensive
options and this does happen but it's
never the only reason formulators use a
particular ingredient number one you
have to make a product that works the
cheapest ingredient is just water but if
a company tried to sell plain water as a
product it would flop really hard number
two price doesn't directly match with
quality i'm sure we all have a favorite
cheap meal that we'd happily pick over a
bunch of more expensive options and
shout out to this video sponsor the
ordinary most of us have probably tried
some super budget-friendly skincare
products from the ordinary that worked
better than more expensive ones and
sulfates do actually have some really
good properties that make them great in
cleansing products on top of just the
price of the raw material one of the
reasons sulfates work out to be cheap is
because they're multifunctional
obviously they clean really well but
they also foam well more foam doesn't
actually mean a better clean but
psychologically if there isn't that much
foam most people just don't think it's
doing a good job sulfates also help
create a thicker texture and you can
usually add a bit of salt to make a
sulfate product thicken even more
shampoos need to be a little bit thick
so it sits nicely in your hand and you
can get it onto your hair effectively
it also makes it feel more concentrated
a lot of other surfactants don't have
these properties so if you take out the
sulfates you often have to add in a
bunch of other ingredients to boost the
foam and make it thicker which adds to
the cost let's take a look at the
ordinary sulfate 4 cleanser for body and
hair which is a pretty stripped back
shampoo formula sodium laureth sulfate
is the anionic surfactant it's at four
percent which you can hopefully tell
from the name this is pretty low for
shampoo but this also doubles up as a
body wash which normally has lower
amounts so this keeps it gentle
specifically they're using sles2 which
means there's two ethoxy units per
molecule this is the most common type
used in shampoos because it gives a good
balance between cleaning gentleness and
cost apart from the anionic surfactant
we have some other ingredients water is
the first ingredient and that's pretty
important it keeps the surfactants
spread out the right way when you put
them on your hair or skin if it's too
concentrated it's really harsh you do
not want 100 surfactant on your skin or
your hair trust me getting the right
dilution also affects the thickness of
the shampoo polysorbate 20 is another
surfactant it's not as good at cleaning
and it's usually used as a solubilizer
so it might be in there to help the
chocolate dissolve xanthan gum is a
thickener that makes the texture thicker
tocopherol is vitamin e which is an
antioxidant there's a mix of
preservatives which stops the bacteria
mold from having a fun multiplying
festival inside the shampoo you need a
preservative whenever you have a
water-based formula there are chelating
agents which grab onto metal ions metal
lines can make anionic surfactants work
worse especially when there's hard water
chelating agents also help preservatives
work better like i said this is a
relatively simple formula so in other
shampoos you'll have other ingredients
too you might have other surfactants
because combining multiple surfactants
can make a cleanser more gentle some of
them can also boost foam or moisturize
skin shampoos also often have detangling
ingredients because when hair is wet the
cuticle sticks up more so the surface is
rougher and it can snag on other hairs
more easily so most shampoos will have
some ingredients that very thinly coat
the hair to make a smoothing layer the
most common ingredients for these are
polyquaterniums sometimes you'll also
see colorants fragrances and pearlizing
agents to make the shampoo look and
smell nicer my scalp gets dry and
irritated from a lot of shampoos so i
was pretty curious to see how this very
simple formula would go for me this
turned out to be really good for my
scalp one of the better tolerated
shampoos i've used having multiple
surfactants is usually good because it
reduces irritation but they've gotten
around this by using a low percentage of
a gentle type of sles there also isn't
any fragrance in this i personally like
a bit of fragrance in my hair products
but i know a lot of people want or need
to avoid it it's actually pretty hard to
find fragrance free hair products so i'm
really happy to see this available as an
option now onto hair conditioners hair
conditioners have a few more functions
than shampoo and different people use
them for different purposes if you have
short hair you might not actually need
hair conditioner conditioners can add
shine smooth over damage and reduce
tangling and static to do this they
leave a very thin coating on hair
strands there is this myth that cheap
conditioners will coat hair but
expensive ones don't this is not true
you need a coating because your hair is
dead and as it grows it accumulates
damage and ends up looking chipped like
this hair conditioner smooth over this
roughness by plugging in the gaps so
hair doesn't snag and cause more of
these bits to break off the main
ingredients used in hair conditioners
are cationic surfactants these are a lot
like the anionic surfactants we saw in
shampoos except they have a positively
charged head when hair is wet it gets a
negative charge and the damaged bits of
hair usually have a stronger negative
charge opposite charges attract and so
these positive heads in the cationic
surfactants help them stick to the
negatively charged hair the positive
charges are also handy because
once you have enough attached the hair
becomes slightly positive which will
actually repel extra cationic
surfactants what this means is you end
up with a thinner more even film that
feels silky rather than the sort of film
that you might get with a lot of oils
like your natural hair oil that's heavy
and weighs hair down the most common
type of cationic surfactant that you'll
see in conditioners are quaternary
ammonium ions nicknamed quartz you'll
see ownium in a lot of their names the
ordinary's conditioner has two percent
behendramonium chloride in conditioners
these cationic surfactants are usually
combined with fatty alcohols the most
common fatty alcohol is saterial alcohol
which is a mix of settle and sterile
alcohol these fatty alcohols make the
conditioner thicker so it's easier to
apply in your hair more importantly it
also combines with these cationic
surfactants to make an ordered
arrangement called a lamellar structure
this is a bit like a pile of flat tiles
that can slide over each other and coat
the hair these main ingredients are also
why a lot of people get breakouts on
their back with conditioner cationic
surfactants are quite irritating and
fatty alcohols are pretty good at
clogging pores so if you find you get a
lot of back acne make sure you scrub
your back properly after using
conditioner the ordinary's conditioner
is again pretty simple they've only got
seven ingredients so there's the
cationic surfactant and the fatty
alcohol which are the standard
ingredients in every hair conditioner
that form that thin conditioning film we
also have water and just like in
shampoos it's there to make sure
everything is at the right concentration
and thickness for putting on your wet
hair there's also gua gum which thickens
up the formula more and of course
there's preservatives to control
bacteria and mold with more complex
conditioners you might have extra
ingredients and these change the sorts
of coatings left on the hair silicones
are really common and there is a huge
range of these some tend to be heavier
and people get the impression that
silicones always weigh hair down but
this is not a blanket rule some
silicones like my favorite
amodimethicone are charged and so just
like the cationic surfactant you only
get a thin film and any excess stuff
actually gets repelled there are other
polymers like polyquaternium similar to
what's used in shampoos to detangle and
add volume you might see natural oils
like coconut and argan oil these tend to
form thicker films on hair and this
really weighs it down and so usually
they're used at low concentrations and
conditioners you might also have
hydrolyzed proteins and amino acids
these can penetrate into the hair a bit
and add strength by plugging holes in
the hair i was actually quite surprised
by how well this worked on my hair if
you followed my hair bleaching journey
you'll know that i pretty much need
specialized silicones like emo
dimethicone to make my hair not be straw
this conditioner detangled my hair
really nicely when i was washing it and
it felt nice for about a day
but by day two my hair started feeling a
bit dry i think this would have been
fantastic for my hair before i bleached
it but now i need those extra damaged
coating ingredients so i would recommend
trying this if your hair is not quite
this level of damaged if you want a
conditioner that doesn't weigh your hair
down or if you want something fragrance
free again there really aren't that many
options for fragrance-free hair
conditioners so i'm really happy to see
this as an option for people who want it
i hope you enjoyed this deep dive into
shampoos and conditioners let me know if
you're interested in other product
breakdowns make sure you like and
subscribe links to the ordinary's hair
products are in the description more
videos about cosmetic science are
popping up around me now